these are the teeth of someone who lived
a thousand years ago and these are the
teeth of the average person today notice
anything different they didn't have
three color toothpaste back then they
didn't have dentists they didn't even
know what floss was there was no such
thing as paying money for a teeth
cleaning or paying $300 on fillings or
$3,000 on implants or $10,000 on veneers
and yet somehow our ancestors still had
Perfect Teeth whereas today even though
we have the most advanced technology in
the history of time the average family
will still have to sucker out over
$2,000 a year on their teeth so why why
is this the case well to find out I
decided to ask an Insider this is Trisha
O'Hare she's been a dental hygienist for
more than 50 years she's also the
president of O'Hara University and has
written a bunch of books on why our
teeth keep getting worse and how we can
fix it hunter gatherers never had gum
disease because they didn't eat
carbohydrates they hunted killed an
animal ate the animal and were full for
a long time and then a few several days
later they would go get another one when
the diet changed to more Agricultural
and more processed foods um that's when
we began to see differences in dental
disease um alignment of the teeth and
even switching from nose breathing to
mouth breathing which then caused all
the teeth to be crowded a yes carbs were
the key see although we do need carbs
Hunter gathers mostly lived off of foods
like meat and fruits but farming changed
all of that suddenly everyone's di
shifted heavily towards carbs like
potatoes corn wheat and bread carbs that
are broken down into sugar even as you
chew and since sugar is food for the
bacteria that causes plaque and Cavities
even though those Farmers weren't eating
any actual sugar like cookies and Candy
their teeth still suffered and then came
the actual sugar when sugar was first
introduced or honey the only people who
ate it were the rich people the poor
people couldn't afford it so the poor
people had much healthier mouths and the
rich had a lot more dental disease we
have like 800 different species in the
mouth but if you don't eat sugar you
have healthy bacteria but if you eat
sugar the bad bacteria metabolize that
sugar and produce the acid that that
causes the cavity in the tooth bad
bacteria also climb under the gums and
cause gum disease and sugar even comes
out in the fluid between the gum in
their tooth the introduction of refined
sugar started rotting people's teeth in
medieval Europe Dental diseases became
such a big issue that people were
actually asking their Barbers to pull
out bad teeth for them these Barber
surgeons weren't exactly experts and
sometimes they did a lot more harm than
good they had no idea why teeth were bad
they were just there to do the pulling
for you these tooth Jers as they were
called would wrench Smash and knock your
teeth out using a terrifying instrument
called a dental key and these tooth
drawers would be the early origins of
good old Dentistry fast forward to the
early 1900s and Dentistry started
looking a lot more like what it does
today but people's teeth were still
worse off than ever and no one could
understand why today we know why it's
because of our carb and sugar heavy
diets but guess what else was starting
to Boom in the 1900s ah yes big sugar
and big sugar was going to do everything
in their power to hide the truth
[Music]
and by the way guys you know how Trisha
said earlier even switching from nose
breathing to mouth breathing which then
caused all the teeth to be crowded yes
that is right breathing through your
mouth will actually crowd your teeth
that's because your tongue isn't there
to push your teeth out so if you want
better teeth among many benefits you got
to stop mouth breathing you just got to
be conscious of it throughout the day
the problem is when you first try to
mouth breathe through your nose it's
going to be tough to get air enough
first because those Airways haven't been
used in so long that is why trasure
recommends using a nasal spray every day
to open up those passageways using the
clear nasal spray on each side to make
sure your nasal passages are open the
one she's talking about is called clear
and we'll link it below treasure is not
affiliated with clear but we are the the
sponsor of this video I literally use
Clear every day when I brush my teeth
I've gotten all my loved ones on this
because because on top of helping you
breathe better every time I felt like I
was catching a cold or a cough I would
just use this nasal spray and it would
stop that's because this spray has
Xylitol in it a natural sugar alcohol
and when sprayed into your nose the zyl
binds to the cells on your throat
preventing viruses from binding to it
and most cold and coughs and Co you're
going to get is going to be through your
nose so that's why you have to clean it
can't recommend clear enough it's also
really affordable and you can pick it up
on Amazon with the link
below as far back as the 1950s Us big
sugar knew full well what everyone's
teeth was rotting but obviously you
couldn't let the masses know the truth
imagine if everyone knew sugar was the
reason why their teeth were falling out
and that sugar was costing them hundreds
of dollars in dental bills no one would
buy your food like substances anymore so
you went on the offensive you got your
buddies in the government to make sure
that none of the research into tooth
decay ever mentioned sugar as a possible
cause the the sugar industry was very
instrumental in pushing research that
covered up sugar as the cause of disease
and highlighted that fat caused heart
disease and fat made you fat and the way
they did this is they actually paid
researchers they paid um there's
evidence of there must be more but at
least two researchers from Harvard who
published research reviews that the
sugar industry actually had final sign
off on that showed that fat caused heart
disease and fat made people fat but
there was no um inclusion of sugar in
all this even though there was a lot of
sugar research that was done and the the
sugar industry actually destroyed the
career of the researcher John yudkin in
the UK who did the original research
about sugar and they just destroyed his
career and and um attacked him as a
professional and lied about him and then
he kind of disappeared but his book uh
Pure White and deadly was resurrected
Again by um a pediatric endocrinologist
in La who had it republished because he
was seeing um his name is Robert lustic
he saw um little kids 8-year-olds with
non-alcoholic fatty liver
disease and he realized that it was all
the fruit juices because the fructose
the fruit juice and high fructose corn
serer goes right to the liver and is
turned into fat and too much fructose in
the diet was causing disease in the
liver for 8-year-olds that he didn't
realize all the work that had been done
and covered up about sugar causing
systemic disease like this so but even
after all these coverups the truth
started slowly coming out more and more
researchers were making the link between
sugar and dental disease but strangely
enough most people today don't really
know that sugar is the main cause of
tooth diseases why is that shouldn't
this be common knowledge well it's
because that not only did Big Sugar not
want people to know about this but as a
dentist you also weren't very motivated
to tell your patients about the dangers
of
[Music]
sugar think about it as a dentist your
business was now booming thanks to all
this tooth decay $300 filling $3,000 imp
Place $10,000 veneers in today's money
you were a very happy beneficiary in
this tooth decay epidemic so deep down
why would you want the tooth decay to
stop why would you want the masses to
have clean teeth at the end of the day
you make money on costly operations so
one more person with clean teeth is one
less customer so you and your dentist
buddies got together in a dimly lit room
to concoct a plan to keep people's teeth
decaying well actually no that didn't
happen things usually don't work like
this usually in actuality it was more of
hey I'm a rich dentist I would like to
keep being rich oh you say sugar is 100%
the only cost of tooth decay well I'm
just going to subconsciously ignore that
oh would you look at that you need a
tooth implant that would be one kidney
please this is the incentive that many
dentists have think about it yourself
when you go to the dentist unless you're
doing a very profitable operation you
see the dentist for maybe 5 seconds if
at all and in those 5 Seconds they're
like oh make sure you floss okay I got
to go now bye which is why over the next
few decades instead of educating your
patients to prevent tooth decay to
prevent disease you and your fellow
dentist came up with a bunch of weird
obscure protocols that don't even
address the root cause you need a brush
twice a day use fluide toothpaste don't
rinse just spit wait hour research says
you need a brush at least 2 minutes
twice a day oh and don't forget to floss
you do so much stuff at people that's
practically impossible for most people
to keep up with it now every time
someone comes into your office with a
cavity and swear that they were brushing
twice a day and flossing you don't blame
it on the sugar in their diet you just
accuse them of forgetting something on
your list oh but do you brush for 2
minutes at a time how often do you floss
oh you're rinsing after you brush you're
not giving the toothpaste any time to
work and guess what nine times out of 10
they will always fall short of your
expectations on at least one of those
things and so you're in the clear the
blame is plac on them you bring out your
tools drill some holes fill them back up
and boom their money is placed into your
pocket but here is the most magical part
about this whole business it's that the
more holes they get drilled in their
teeth the more Dentistry they have the
more likely they're going to have to
come back the one of the biggest risk
factors for getting dental disease
besides sugar is going to the dentist
because every time you have a filling
put in it cuts the a hole in the tooth
put in a restoration then you have that
margin around the filling of the crown
and microscopically that's a nice big
place for bacteria to accumulate
microscopic you can't see them but
they're there and the more sugar you
feed them the more acid they produce and
you could get cavities right around the
tooth that already got a filling so
people don't understand how they're
getting cavities when they already had
the fillings but definitely def l a risk
the more Dentistry you have the more
likely you are to have more dental
disease did you listen to that ladies
and gentlemen the more Dentistry you
have the more likely you are to have
more dental disease that is the great
scam of dentistry and that's why you can
finally go pick up that new Porsche and
naturally as time went on you were
finding all sorts of things in your
patients to perform bigger and more
expensive procedures on oh you have a
cavity let's take a bunch of expensive
x-rays even though I can clearly see how
deep it is hm the cavity I filed is
still hurting it must have reached down
to your nerve endings time for a root
canal even if it was your own bad work
that caused the extra problems you could
just explain it away and charge them
another kidney it was the perfect
business plan but there was just one
small problem some of your subordinates
were threatening to tell the public the
[Music]
truth you know how when you go to the
dentist for a regular cleaning is not
actually the dentist that cleans your
teeth no regular teeth cleanings don't
make money so dentists relegate that
plean work to their underlings the
dental hygienist dental hygienists are
not full on dentists they're beneath
them that way the dentist keeps their
really lucrative operations all to
themselves but guess what these dental
hygienists are actually trained to do
exactly what you despise their job is to
help patients prevent tooth disease
before it happens now we can't have that
now can we the hygienists are taught how
to treat some disease but also more
importantly how to prevent dental
disease and how to prevent Dentistry if
let loose we could cure dental disease
because we know how what's causing it
and we know what to do and another
interesting fact is that 80% of the work
that the dentist does in the dental
practice comes through the patients that
see the hygienist so if they don't have
a hygienist working bringing in all
these patients for the quote unquote
cleanings there wouldn't be any work for
the dentist to do so they use it as a
way to get more work more patience
absolutely and it used to be a lost
leader where they didn't even charge
enough to to pay the hygienist to do it
because they got so much work from it
but now the hygienists are more Highly
Educated they need to be compensated so
the dentists are complaining about that
too and for years this was fine the
hygienist remainder underlings they made
a tiny fraction of the money you make
and they definitely don't have as much
status as you and so life was good but
then they started to get smarts they
started becoming more independent they
wanted to open up their own practices
and worse yet they wanted to take your
profitable patience with them which
meant that if you didn't do anything
about this if you didn't squash this
little Uprising your Lively Hood your
status would all go swirling down the
sink but luckily you knew just the way
to fight back with a cartel a cartel
that goes by the name of the American
Dental
[Music]
Association
so their dentists especially the
American Dental Association is really
afraid of hygienists going out on their
own the American Dental Association or
Ada has complete control over What
treatments dentist and hygienists are
allowed to do they're basically in
control of the entire careers of dentist
and hygienists the education is
controlled by the dental association
their Commission on Dental accreditation
and they control what education dent
have and hygienists have because both of
these educational programs lead to a
license but here's the thing even though
the Ada has all this power over dental
hygienists only dentists and dental
students are allowed to be members no
hygienist allowed you know what that
means right since hygienists don't get a
say over their own profession you can
suffocate them and keep them under your
control they have always stated that
dental hygiene should be a 2-year entry
to practice but they allow the hygiene
Association and Ed Educators to add more
input into the content of the education
so now they've added so much to the
education that it's actually just short
of a master's degree and they still
require that it be a 2-year entry and
something they did in the 70s which is
interesting is they had an organized
plan to push all dental hygiene programs
out of universities where they were
getting a bachelor's degree into
community colleges so they forced the
hygienist to have a 2-year degree but
but now we have almost 250 Community
College programs for dental hygien so
they study for 5 years two years of
prerequisites and three years squashed
into two to get their 2-year degree the
real reason is that dental hygiene has
allowed dentists to control the
education if you're a profession you
have to control your own education so we
are actually as dental hygienists
considered auxiliaries of Dentistry not
true professionals thanks to this small
change hygienist can only ever work
under your supervision and Most states
are not even allowed to practice on
their own or decide on treatments
without your inputs the reason they want
to do this is they don't want dental
hygienist to be independent because if
hygienists had a higher level degree
they could then achieve independence and
work on their own outside the dental
office and the dentists are afraid if
that happens only the good dentists will
get referrals and the bad dentist won't
have any work here is what all of this
means in practice when you go in for a
cleaning or a checkup a hygienist might
spot City in one of your teeth but under
no circumstances are they allowed to
tell you instead all they can do is make
a note of it for the dentist so that you
can pay for expensive X-rays and be
charged for another consultation just to
be sure dental hygienists aren't even
allowed to use that little mirror to
further inspect cavities without first
getting the dentist's permission that is
how far the Ada has gone to make sure
that dental hygienists are seen as
nothing more than the equivalent of
nurses and all of this worked dentists
continue to get rich while your teeth
and your wallet continue to suffer so
how do you actually go about protecting
your teeth on your own since your
dentist might not have your best
interest at
heart okay out of curiosity if you were
to raise a kid like from the ground up
kind of like how we grew up as hunter
gatherers without you know process
sugars and stuff like that would their
teeth just be perfectly healthy and not
crowded and all that stuff Absolut mhm
their teeth would be perfectly healthy
so the first one is obvious reduce the
amount of sugar and carbs you're
consuming and opt for more meat now if
you're eating healthy organic clean cars
form quality ingredients with meat is
probably not as big of an issue your
body does need sugar this is more for
those that are chugging sodas energy
drinks and processed snacks all the time
and what happens when you eat processed
food especially with sugar when it's
metabolized it gives off CO2 and that
goes through from the stomach to the
bloodstream into the lungs and then it
has to be exhaled and there's so much
more of the CO2 the normal that they
switch from nose breathing which keeps
the tongue on the roof of the mouth
making the jaw all grow wide and they
tongue drops they open their mouth and
cheeks P push in and they get all
crooked teeth yes that is right too much
sugar can actually turn you into a mouth
Brea which can lead to even more
crowning of your teeth which will meet
another round of expensive braces we
could do a whole video on mouth
breathing it's really really really bad
and you just got to be self-aware when
you're mouth braving you got to rush
your tongue against the roof of your
mouth and that's pretty much it but when
you first start trying to breath through
your nose it's probably going to be a
little tough the less you use your nose
the less you're going to be able to use
your nose just like any other muscle so
when people start habitually breathing
through their mouths their noses are
going to start to close up and we know
this from the doctor of speech language
pathology at Stanford she measured
people who had uh laryngectomies holes
drilled in their throats so they could
breathe she found between 2 months and 2
years their noses were completely
blocked zero air coming in so the more
you use it the more you're going to be
able to use it so the less you use it
the more apt you will you will be to
have problems that is why Trisha
recommends using a nasal spray every day
to open up those passage ways using the
clear nasal spray on each side to make
sure your nasal passages are open which
again we'll link to the clear nasal
spray below again Trish is not
affiliated with clear but we are that
the sponsor of this video Trish also has
a unique take on brushing your teeth
I've written the book about dry brushing
so don't brush with toothpaste brush
without toothpaste brush the inside of
the bottom teeth first brush the whole
mouth without toothpaste until the mouth
feels clean and tastes clean and only
then add toothpaste
and to clean between the teeth you can
use a water flosser you can use an
interdental brush all kinds of things
picks sticks or if you want to floss you
can but if you floss be sure you get a
squeak when you wrap it around and go up
and down to scrape the bacteria off the
teeth you need to get a squeak what is a
squeak a squeak you know a squeaky clean
like when your hair is really clean and
squeaky and when like you clean a window
it's kind of squeaks if you get the
bacteria off your teeth with the dental
flow loss you will get a squeak but if
you just go lightly you're still leaving
a layer of bacteria on the teeth so as
you can tell Trisha has been a huge help
for this video and from talking to her
you can tell that she really cares about
helping people so I'll link to her stuff
below for you to check out if you're
interested stay dangerous and we'll see
you in the next
[Music]
one